[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans votre magazine
de l'éducation 12 millions d'élèves se
rendent chaque matin à l'école au
collège ou au lycée mais ça vous
vraiment comment se déroule leur journée
qui sont tous ceux qui font l'école et
comment s'organisent-ils ne bougez pas
vous allez tout savoir grâce à liberté
égalité scolarité et voici tout de suite
le sommaire
on vous emmène au lycée de la mer et du
littoral un établissement qui prépare
les élèves aux métiers aquacols et à la
gestion des milieux naturels vous allez
le voir une filière professionnelle
pensée dans le respect de
l'environnement
il conduit tous les matins les
collégiens des villages alentours et les
ramènent tous les soirs à la maison
rencontre avec un chauffeur de bus
scolaire
Gael Faye a connu ses premiers
instituteurs au Burundi puis il a
atterri au collège à Versailles de cette
double expérience scolaire il garde le
souvenir de professeurs passionnés qui
lui montre en semi le goût des mots
c'est notre rubrique mémoire d'école
enfin en archives nous reviendrons sur
les cours de sciences de la vie et de la
terre de la bonne vieille leçon de
choses aux sciences de l'environnement
nous verrons comment cette discipline
s'est adaptée à l'air du temps
[Musique]
le saviez-vous pour devenir
ostréiculteur il faut avoir un diplôme
d'ostréiculture ça tombe bien c'est à
cela qu'on prépare les élèves en filière
professionnelle du lycée de la mer et du
littoral nous sommes juste en face de
l'île d'Oléron et comme la mer est
partout ici les Bac Pro s'appellent
culture marine production aquacol ou
encore gestion des milieux naturels des
diplômes qui sentent bon l'air marins et
la protection de l'environnement venez
voir
[Musique]
bonjour
Qu'est-ce que vous êtes en train de
faire alors aujourd'hui on va faire un
TP on va apprendre des élèves à calculer
des rations alimentaires sur des dorades
royales donc c'est des poissons qui
vivent en eau de mer et aujourd'hui on
va leur montrer comment poser les
poissons pour pouvoir réajuster la
relation alimentaire et faire ça dans le
respect du bien-être animal et voilà
donc on va s'occuper du bassin M6 vous
allez Dean donc nos poissons ont l'air
d'avoir un comportement plutôt pas trop
stressé donc prenez la température vous
savez comment faire
la température de l'eau elle est de 22,5
vous allez faire c'est que vous allez
vous coordonner d'accord comme je vous
ai dit
[Musique]
c'est bon
voilà là on a des jeunes dorates il faut
qu'il calcule le poids moyen donc ils
vont nous faire ça
ça fait combien
[Musique]
donc là ça veut dire qu'on va distribuer
172 G
d'aliments et c'est quel aliment vous
avez le nom
[Musique]
combien de millimètres de diamètre voilà
7,5
du poisson vous avez tous entendu qu'il
y a de moins en moins de poissons dans
l'océan avec la surface etc donc la quoi
culture depuis pas longtemps produit
plus de poissons qu'on empêche donc il y
a vraiment une tendance à ce que les
produits de la quoi culture remplacent
les produits issus de la pêche avec un
aspect du coup
environnemental en tout cas avec une
envie de protéger l'environnement parce
que en gros on va récupérer les déchets
des poissons et on va s'en servir comme
engrais pour des plantes on va récupérer
les bouts des c'est à dire les fesses
c'est extrêmement des poissons et on
s'en sert pour faire du compostage donc
on essaye de faire un cercle vertueux
voilà récupérer les déchets de plus en
plus pour les revaloriser et pour s'en
servir comme ressources pour refaire
d'autres cycles élevages et pour ça il
faut former de plus en plus de jeunes
j'imagine voilà et ça c'est vraiment une
branche où il y a plus de demandes de
recrutement que de d'élèves qui sortent
diplômés donc c'est vraiment un métier
d'avenir tous les élèves qui sortent
avec le diplôme ils trouvent tous du
travail alors avant d'avoir du travail
il faut qu'il fasse le mais ils sont
très intéressés et du coup ils
apprennent très vite
explique-moi toi un petit peu pourquoi
tu as choisi ce diplôme parce que ça
m'intéresse ça peut me former sur mon
prochain métier
après je peux aussi faire travailler
dans les aquariums on discutait avec ton
prof de l'environnement de la protection
de l'environnement est-ce que toi ça
fait aussi un peu partie de de tes idées
quand tu choisis ce bac pro
ça sera avec la responsabilité de pas
toucher l'écosystème avoir une bonne
production tout en étant éco-responsable
ok super chouette bon bah on te laisse
finir de son exercice
[Musique]
tu vas venir faire une sécurité en
revanche par dessus
super alors là on est près d'un clair
c'est ça oui c'est ça là on est sur
l'éclairs ostréicoles donc c'est les
bassins à fond argileux qui sont
utilisés plutôt pour les cultures
l'élevage des huîtres mais on fait aussi
de l'élevage de crevettes dans ces
clercs et donc là c'est une TP
d'aujourd'hui c'est un TP sur les
crevettes
je pensais que vous devez les
transporter
voilà ça fait partie ce qu'on leur
apprend aussi les gestes professionnels
toujours porter les charges lourdes à
deux essayez de manipuler sans se faire
mal très important écarte bien le filet
avant et là ce que tu peux faire c'est
tu vas l'aider Léo vous les répartissez
toutes pour qu'elles arrivent dans la
première poche
alors vous allez peut-être pouvoir nous
montrer une crevette ah comme ça à la
main là à la main mais on pense pas
alors normalement quand on les prend de
la bonne façon mais là sur ta main pour
qu'elle tienne voilà donc ça c'est la
crevette impériale japonaise donc on
appelle comment
c'est bon c'est laquelle la poubelle de
crevette
allez on y va
[Musique]
alors là on est en cours de quoi
alors ici c'est un cours de système
d'information géographique aménagement
et puis il y a aussi de la science de la
vie et de la terre ça ça s'inscrit dans
un bac pro alors gestion des milieux
naturels et de la faune je suis MNF pour
les Antilles il va y avoir deux groupes
qui vont s'occuper du trait de côte ils
vont faire un suivi du trait de côte
pour le protéger pour le protéger
constater aussi son recul ou pas c'est
parti c'est parti
[Musique]
tu visualise le trait de côte à peu près
tu vois c'est le pied de la dune le
trait de côte il est là
il longe cette lune on le voit bien donc
on va planter voilà ce qui nous
intéresse sont les coordonnées
géographiques latitude longitude mais
aussi l'altitude tout simplement et tu
peux prendre ta photo comme tu veux
est-ce que ces données potentiellement
elles peuvent être réutilisées ou en
tout cas retravailler à travers un cours
de mathématiques par exemple ou un cours
de science de la vie et de la terre
on peut l'étudier après en cours de
maths en étudiant les la série
temporelle qu'on a récupéré et puis même
parfois en éducation socio-culturelle
parce que peut-être qu'il va falloir
indiquer aux gens qu'il y a des accès à
pas prendre parce qu'on remarque que la
plage ça fait davantage à cet endroit là
donc il y a une partie communication
aussi qui est importante qu'ils
apprennent aussi à travers ce bac pro et
qu'ils apprennent aussi à travers ce bac
pro
pourquoi tu l'as choisi toi ce bac pro
pour faire ensuite un garde forestier OK
et apprendre ce type de ben voilà de
savoir faire pour toi c'est important
oui parce que si on doit traverser en
forêt et relever un certain nombre
d'arbres qui faut absolument enlever
parce qu'il risque de devenir un danger
potentiel sur les voies il faudra les
relever avec le GPS le bac professionnel
voilà ça conduit peut-être un peu plus
vite vers un métier c'est quelque chose
qui te oui c'est ça on apprend des
choses qui seront vraiment utiles et on
apprend moins de choses qui pourront
être
inutiles
[Musique]
tous les matins Jean-Christophe Rouxel
ramasse les collégiens des
établissements voisins c'est normal me
direz-vous c'est même son métier
puisqu'il est conducteur de car scolaire
cet arrêt jalonnent son parcours pour
conduire chaque matin et ramener chaque
soir les enfants qu'ils découvrent en 6e
et qu'il finit par bien connaître en
troisième il est 7h30 nous sommes pile à
l'heure pour le départ
[Musique]
bonjour
ça va
[Musique]
bien merci
12 ans maintenant que vous conduisez les
enfants le matin et aussi le soir pour
rentrer chez eux ça crée des liens
ah oui ça m'est arrivé d'avoir des
enfants que j'ai eu 6 ans deux ans en
primaire et 4 ans au collège donc
automatiquement à se dire bonjour matin
et soir à se poser des questions de
temps en temps si ça va au collège etc
il arrive même que les parents je les
connaissent qui m'envoient des textos
quand pour prévenir que leur enfant par
exemple ne prennent pas le car le matin
donc automatiquement ça crée des liens
[Musique]
ça fait combien de temps que vous prenez
le bus tous les matins
vous le connaissez bien le conducteur du
bus oui très bien et lui vous pose des
questions des fois oh bah oui la journée
s'est bien passée impeccable ah ouais ok
sympa
[Musique]
bonjour bonjour
les briefs dès la première semaine en 6e
je leur explique d'une part qu'ils
doivent présenter leur carte au moment
où ils montent dans le car ils doivent
s'asseoir si possible à la même place
pendant tout le trajet et pas bouger
entre chaque arrêt qui doivent avoir
leur gilet c'est pour être bien vu au
bord de la route et donc quand c'est
expliqué un peu dans cette méthode là
c'est je pense mieux compris que un
règlement peut réduire appliqué
tous les matins profiter du bus pour
réviser
quatre balles aujourd'hui donc du coup
le trajet en bus ça vous aide à réviser
encore un petit peu jusqu'au dernier
moment il conduit doucement ça vous
permet de lire aussi je vous laisserai
viser alors je croise les doigts pour
vos
alors là on arrive dans le fond du bus
c'est normalement au fond du bus c'est
une place qui est un peu réservée non
vous êtes toujours à cette place là
quand vous étiez en sixième vous étiez
plus devant le premier jour on était
vraiment devant proche du pare-brise
donc c'est un peu un privilège d'être au
fond du bus oui
[Musique]
vous travaillez le matin et le soir en
fait j'embauche à 7h30 et je termine à
8h45 et je reprends à 15h55 pour finir à
18h
c'est un métier qui est en pénurie
aujourd'hui on en cherche plein c'est un
métier qui est contraignant c'est un
métier qui est pas très très bien
reconnu peut-être aussi c'est compliqué
pour celui qui n'a pas une autre
activité à côté puisque en effet il va
travailler le matin et le soir donc on
aurait décalé pour peu qu'il habite un
peu loin il est obligé de faire deux
allers-retours un matin et un le soir
pour pour travailler donc au vu du prix
de l'énergie en revue net à la fin du
mois s'il a pas autre chose que que son
mi-temps de conducteur de car scolaire
c'est très compliqué vous avez l'air
d'être heureux dans votre métier de vous
voir comme ça avec
un autre une autre activité à côté qui
qui m'épanouit grandement également et
les deux sont complémentaires en timing
ça y est elle a tourné terminée la
journée c'est fini pour vous oui je vais
juste vérifier qu'on qui a pas un
collégien qui aurait oublié quelque
chose voir qui se sera endormi mais bon
ça m'étonnerait et puis en effet ma
matinée est terminée et ben on vous
laisse alors merci beaucoup au revoir au
revoir
[Musique]
comment ça va lundi mardi mercredi jeudi
vendredi bien dormir le weekend bien
passé ta grande et la famille les
enfants les amis le barbec annulé par la
pluie il a passé les 13 premières années
de sa vie au Burundi ensuite il a
poursuivi ses études en France à
Versailles aujourd'hui c'est l'un des
auteurs et rappeurs les plus brillants
de sa génération alors où a bien pu
naître son amour inconditionnel des mots
à l'école en France au Burundi on va
demander tout ça à Monsieur Gael Faye
comme un indice comme un lundi bonjour
Gaël Faye bonjour merci de nous accorder
un petit peu de votre temps j'ai une
première question à vous poser vous avez
passé les 13 premières années de votre
vie au Burundi c'était comment l'école
là-bas c'était une très belle école très
grande où on pouvait rentrer en
maternelle et sortir en terminale donc
avec toutes les générations dans la même
enceinte c'était aussi très cosmopolite
il y avait bien sûr des Burundais des
rondins des Congolais donc des gens de
la région mais il y avait aussi beaucoup
de gens de passage à l'Est c'était la
grande époque de la coopération
française donc il y avait beaucoup de
copains en français avec leurs enfants
il y avait des gens des instituts des
institutions internationales donc leurs
enfants étaient là et alors vous avez
une photo de cette photo de cette époque
là c'est une des rares photos que j'ai
de cette époque donc voilà donc quand je
parle de voilà il y a toutes les
couleurs
là je suis en scène de là moi je vous
êtes juste ici avec un œil fermé il y a
trop de soleil et voilà Monsieur Bournat
qui était un jeune prof français de 27
ans qui était super en quoi il était
super il avait beaucoup d'humour il
essayait vraiment de nous mettre à
l'aise je me souviens le premier jour il
a dit bon je veux pas que vous fassiez
les pitres et il a fait le poirier tout
de suite et on était tous mort de rire
et quel type d'élèves vous étiez très
rêveur très très timide ouais à me
cacher un petit peu à toujours regarder
par la fenêtre
assez effacé mais intéressé ouais
intéressé par ce qui se passait ouais
justement les cours de ce monsieur les
apprentissages ça vous parlait quand
même un peu
il y a des matières que je préférais
plus que d'autres forcément l'histoire
et la géographie j'aimais bien parce que
c'était déjà on racontait des ailleurs
on me racontait
des histoires du
paysage et donc ça faisait déjà
travailler l'imagination on va compter
déjà
ce mon port de ou aussi l'histoire de de
votre région de je parle du Rwanda du
Burundi mais malheureusement on ne
parlait pas de l'histoire de la région
parce que moi j'étais dans un lycée
français et donc oui on parlait de on
avait le programme français et donc ça
c'est
plus tard à l'adolescence je me suis
rendu compte qu'il y avait comme une
contradiction parce que parce que on
savait pas on connaissait pas ce qui
s'était passé dans le pays quand la
guerre est apparue au Burundi
on s'est posé des questions sur
finalement d'où venait tous ces conflits
de quelle histoire on était issus et oui
je savais mieux parler de l'histoire de
France que l'histoire du Bondier du
Rwanda la guerre 1993
euh et vous arrivez en France vous
arrivez en France à Versailles au
collège
expliquez-moi c'est un choc un choc
je vais dire
déjà de paysages d'un coup je passais de
cette très grande cour de récréation
avec des arbres il faisait beau toute
l'année à une toute petite cour de
récréation du béton partout des arbres
sans feuilles et puis voilà le manque de
lumière donc moi c'est ça d'un coup tout
s'assombrit parce qu'on se lève le matin
il fait nuit on rentre de l'école il
fait nuit tout ça c'est des choses que
je ne connaissais pas j'apprends aussi à
m'excuser de d'avoir
de venir d'ailleurs d'avoir une autre
histoire de pas connaître les références
c'était des beaucoup de choses comme ça
c'était une période d'adaptation et
heureusement à l'adolescence on s'adapte
vite bien
est-ce que vous avez un prof une prof
une matière qui vous aurait marqué au
collège oui là c'est le français avec
Madame boulanger en troisième qui
commence à nous faire lire des livres
qui m'intéressent et on doit faire des
fiches de lecture on doit en parler en
classe et donc moi j'ai eu un coup de
cœur pour L'Étranger de Camus voilà
et puis
et puis Hugo
Maupassant j'y mets la douceur de cette
femme ça sa façon
de faire de transmettre sa passion même
si la note était pas bonne elle était
toujours encourageante et c'est les
seuls copies moi que j'ai gardé de cette
époque et au lycée à Versailles toujours
vous découvrez la MJC il y avait un DJ
il avait des platines et puis il y avait
un micro et là il y avait des petits
groupes de rap et il passait des
instrumentales et les gars râpés et
alors moi je trouve ça génial j'ai
jamais touché un micro de ma vie
j'ai jamais posé sur une instru je
rappelle pour moi dans ma chambre et
donc je me disais que c'était vraiment
le moyen la possibilité de trouver du
collectif un programme spécifique à
l'éducation nationale via le réseau
canopée qui s'appelle les enfants de
l'Asie ça vous parle bien sûr il y a
deux textes de de vos textes qui ont été
choisis par ce réseau c'est pili sur un
croissant au beurre et lundi méchant ça
vous fait quoi de savoir que
potentiellement dans tous les collèges
de France on peut étudier vos œuvres vos
textes vos chansons vos musiques
extrêmement honoré quoi c'est c'est
extraordinaire c'est un privilège et
puis j'espère surtout que ça ça va
inspirer les élèves quoi donc du coup
lundi méchant ça fait partie des textes
qui ont été donc choisis je peux vous
laisser lire ce passage là enfin vous
devez connaître mais juste celui-ci je
vais pas me laisser démonter par bad
vibes émorosité parce qu'on tenter mais
tenter sinon tes rêves enterrer chauffer
chauffer ou être en temps les pulsations
dans tes tympans chante et chanter ce
cancan écoutez goûter lundi méchant
comme un lundi comme un lundi méchant
j'ai écrit cette chanson en plein en
pleine pandémie voilà avec avec ce qu'on
connaissait des couvre-feu et des
confinements etc donc c'était aussi une
manière un peu combattante de dire bon
on va pas se laisser démonter par la
morosité moi j'ai donné ma version de la
chose après
on peut se lancer dans une chorale
ça serait génial merci beaucoup merci
[Musique]
on le connaît le cours de SVT les
sciences de la vie et de la terre de la
reproduction des espèces au
fonctionnement des volcans en passant
par des dizaines d'autres sujets c'est
une discipline essentielle qui
sensibilise aujourd'hui les jeunes
générations au changement climatique
mais vous allez le voir cet enseignement
n'a pas toujours été à l'honneur retour
en archives dans la capsule old school
préparée par le réseau canopé
[Musique]
dissection maquette du système solaire
collection de cailloux petits élevages
d'animaux la biologie et la géologie
sont longtemps restés pour les
pédagogues des occasions de sortir de la
classe avant de percevoir tout leur
potentiel pour stimuler les élèves
[Musique]
retour sur deux siècles de sciences à
l'école
[Musique]
dans les lycées créés en 1802 les élèves
apprennent essentiellement le latin et
les mathématiques les sciences
n'apparaîtront que lentement pour
accompagner la révolution industrielle
pour les élèves de primaire scolarisés
en nombre à partir de 1833 les sciences
restent facultatives sans Kota horaire
dédié ni programme arrêté
durant le Second Empire Marie pape
Carpentier devient la figure de proue
d'un mouvement de rénovation des
pratiques pédagogiques et pour répondre
à la curiosité des enfants elle imagine
la leçon de choses qui engage à
enseigner à partir du réel
Jules Ferry s'en inspire lorsqu'il rend
obligatoire l'enseignement des sciences
à l'école primaire
en explorant le monde à travers leur
sens les élèves apprennent à nommer
schématiser distinguer et classé mais en
plus ils expérimentent au-delà des
connaissances usuelles l'instruction
républicaine en temps réalisé l'idéal
émancipateur des Lumières
renforcer une première fois dans les
programmes scolaires de 1902 les
sciences bénéficient à la fin des années
50 de l'essor de la télévision scolaire
le monde lointain se transporte dans la
classe et ce média rapproche
scientifique et élève c'est difficile
d'accès d'ailleurs il faut faire des
centaines de kilomètres sur des pistes
qui sont très dures il faut vraiment
avoir envie de s'instruire et de voir
quelque chose d'intéressant pour aller
au total
la psychologie gagne en influence durant
les deux décennies suivantes les
conditions des apprentissages sont
davantage prises en compte incitant les
enseignants à s'appuyer sur les
questionnements et les représentations
des élèves la leçon de choses présentait
l'appareil digestif l'éveil scientifique
fera comprendre la digestion
dans les années 90 l'avènement de
l'informatique fait entrer
l'expérimentation assistée par
ordinateur dans les enseignements
scientifiques la révolution numérique
suivante facilite la compréhension des
phénomènes de l'infiniment grand à
l'infiniment petit
[Musique]
très tôt les sciences de la vie et de la
terre se sont engagés dans l'éducation
développement durable les enseignants de
SVT intègrent des pédagogies actives et
forment l'esprit critique des élèves
utile pour aborder en classe les
questions qui font débats dans la
société comme les OGM ou le nucléaire
au XIXe siècle à l'observation de
l'environnement proche cet enseignement
est aujourd'hui au premier plan pour
aborder les grands enjeux contemporains
de la planète en apprenant à allier
l'investigation l'analyse des faits
scientifiques et le débat les élèves
deviennent acteurs et développent leur
esprit critique et leur capacité à faire
société
et voilà l'émission est déjà terminée
mais on se retrouve très vite pour un
prochain numéro de liberté égalité
scolarité
[Musique]